christian bale steals the show as gore
the god butcher in thor 4 but what's the
story behind his deadly necro sword and
what does it mean for the future of the
mcu keep watching to find out
oh god she will die the marvel cinematic
universe is packed with iconic weapons
and costumes used by the countless
heroes and villains across the
multiverse and it is committed to
expanding that armory in thor love and
thunder in the sequel from thor ragnarok
director taika waititi thor heads off on
a quest to rediscover himself after the
events of avengers end game and he winds
up crossing paths with gore the
godbutcher in the process
in late june gore actor christian bale
told total film he was concerned about
gore's minimal costume in the comics
telling the outlet i thought they don't
have the right man for that and then
taika quickly dispelled any notions of
running around in that but i always did
think what he could do with this in
front of a blue screen he could chuck on
whatever he wants later on thankfully
the live-action version of gore is a
little more covered up and the film does
give the villain his iconic weapon the
necro sword gore uses the jet black
weapon with a devastating fury in the
highly anticipated sequel especially in
a brutal fight with thor jane and
valkyrie in the necroverse but the
origins of the necrosword in the mcu are
just as murky as the blade itself the
object has a fascinating history in the
comics and it could mean that a huge
villain is somewhere on the horizon as
far as the mcu is concerned thor love
and thunder never actually confirms who
the necrosword belongs to before gore
gains control of it instead thor
explains it's been passed down since the
dawn of time and it corrupts anyone who
uses it infecting them with darkness
until they die when gore first gets his
hands on it it's next to a dead knight
wearing a bulky set of black armor who's
clearly succumbed to its influence in
the comics gore's necrosword belongs to
null the symbiote god before the thor
villain gets his claws on it in donny
kate's venom number four the villain
recounts his origin to eddie brock
explaining that billions of years in the
past he lived alone in a void that
quickly became the battleground for a
celestial war because they invade null's
empty kingdom he conjures a sword out of
the void and beheads a celestial before
turning its severed head into a forge
where he makes the necrosword a
permanent weapon essentially it's a
blade of living darkness that also traps
the soul of anything it kills inside it
because null is a key part of the venom
mythology it seems likely that sony has
the rights to use null however it sees
fit even though the studio bought the
rights to spider-man and his related
characters a number of years before the
villain debuted in the comics as such
this is probably why co-writers taika
waititi and jennifer kaden robinson use
an ambiguous figure rather than
acknowledging the null of it all it's
unclear if the two studios could or
would strike a deal for null to appear
in the mcu but it seems far more likely
that he'd show up in a future venom film
with tom hardy's symbiotic anti-hero
first
all of us
[Music]
it's also worth pointing out that the
necro sword is also called the all black
and it's actually the very first
symbiote yes the sword is technically
alive what's interesting is that it also
cloaks null in a set of black armor with
a red insignia on the front which gives
the immortal villain a terrifying look
so the dead knight in the opening of
thor love and thunder clearly a nod to
the necrosword's origins without getting
into the messy implications of null
himself being in the mcu gore briefly
meets null in thor god of thunder number
six where the villain reveals his origin
to an imprisoned volstag the issue
explains that gore is exiled from his
tribe for his rage against the gods and
shortly after he stumbles on an armored
null fighting a golden god in the desert
although their fight has ended in a
stalemate because they've impaled each
other all black quickly jumps into
gore's hand as a dagger and he uses it
to kill the golden god in revenge for
the deaths of his mother his wife and
his daughter over the years that's not
too far from the film's opening where
gore stumbles into rapu's realm and uses
the discarded weapon to kill his former
idol the necrosword symbiote abilities
are a huge part of the film too as gore
brings monstrous black berserkers out of
the abyss inside the necrosword to
plague the asgardians and steal the
children of new asgard when the villain
kills several gods in thor god of
thunder number 1 and number 3 he leaves
a few berserkers behind as sentries to
slaughter anyone investigating their
deaths taika ytt clearly did his
homework
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
thor love and thunder are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]